- So help me God, Chris, if
you ruin my relationship...
I'll kill you.
- I feel like I'm, for the most part,
a pretty, pretty honest,
don't have too many
skeletons in the closet.
- I think he might be a little annoyed,
maybe, pissed off a bit with this secret.
- It was really hard to think of a secret.
I didn't know where to steer that boat.
- I feel like I know a
lot of secrets about Max.
I feel like he knows a lot of my secrets.
And that's what's scary.
- Less of a secret but more of a sneak.
- I'm a little nervous that
my secret is gonna be meaner.
- Well, who's gonna go first?
- No, we're gonna (mumbling).
- Rock, paper, scissors, go.
Oh.
- (laughs) Okay.
- [Both] Scissors!
- Shit, okay.
- That means you're first.
- Do you wanna hold my hands like Oprah?
- All right, so when we started dating,
okay, we were at school.
- (laughs) I'm nervous.
- We weren't living in L.A., right?
But you're from L.A.
Remember that internship
I had where I was like,
so I was working two days a week.
I had an internship and
I would drive up to L.A.
So, this is maybe like a month
and a half into us dating.
So, it turns out, I was
actually staying at your house,
your parents house.
- You weren't.
- I was, I was.
- (laughs) No way.
- Yeah, yeah.
Basically, I was staying at
your house two nights a week.
- As soon as I was old enough
to like girls and think girls are pretty,
I did this weird thing in my head
where I, every time I
saw a girl that I thought
was really pretty, I'd, um...
I was kind of like making
a list but it was like,
I would, I would just
be like... (smooches)
I would blow a little secret kiss to them.
Whether it's on TV or on
the street or anything.
I would be like (smooches) and
I would blow a little kiss,
and then, in my head,
that marked that person
so that when I went to
heaven, they would be there.
- My biggest secret is
that I drink out of the...
the toilet, no.
(both laugh)
I'm a big toilet drinker.
Oh, feels so good.
Aw, do you drink out of
the things in the fridge?
(both laugh)
- All the time, all the time.
- That's it, right, we're done?
- We're good.
- Great, that was great, let's go.
- Don't you have a secret to tell me,
somethin' cute, and I don't know.
- Somethin' cute and
won't hurt your feelings?
- I like pranking people
which you obviously know,
'cause I make you film me
pranking people sometimes,
but, and you know this, I've
told you this in the past,
you have a tendency to
talk during your sleep.
You wake me up in the middle of the night
and you start off with coherent sentences
that start getting really weird like,
yesterday I went to the
mall and blah blah blah
and just mumbling and it's been really--
- I say yesterday I went to the mall?
- Or whatever, you just start off with
coherent phrases that turn
into I don't know what.
It sounds like you're
possessed or something.
But I've been recording
you and putting them up
onto my Snapchat Stories,
but it's like an inside joke
between my friends and I, so... (laughs)
You've gotten me a bunch
more followers on Snapchat.
- Wow, so, how many, wait, okay,
this is blowing my mind a little bit.
How long you been doing this for?
(laughs)
- Just like six months.
- Six, six months, are you kidding me?
- With my ex-boyfriend, we
went up to my elementary
school roof in the middle of the night
and we had sex on the roof
and no one knows about that.
- Well, he does.
- Yup.
- And now I do and now a
lot of people do. (laughs).
Uh, cool.
That's dope.
(both laugh)
- Sometimes when I'm cooking dinner,
I will drop something on the floor
and I just put it on your plate.
- Okay.
(both laugh)
- But the reason I don't
feel that bad about it
is I know you'd eat it anyway.
- Well, I'm not a billy goat.
(both laugh)
- It's weird that he's in my room,
the room I grew up in,
while I was at college.
That's very weird.
- I kinda wish mine was a little cuter.
- I just feel ashamed.
I feel a lot of shame.
- You really should.
- I'm a little bit curious
about what this new thing
that's been brought into my life
which is that, apparently, I sleep talk.
And apparently there's
video of me doing it.
- Just now that I've heard your secret,
I'm extremely upset.
- Everything that made you the
person you are today is dope.
- Aw.
You're the sweetest.